tutela a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono qua vigenti e
dolcissimo su what the dead le sketch
chi non conosce 8 dei non si spaventi
perché potrebbe sembrare strano e anche
tanto da ragazzino mi ricordo perché
come ci si muove sempre che ci si muova
come ci si muoveva nel primo perché non
è che vi sto per sposare ragazzi del mio
matrimonio neanche lo sapevo se no ok
perfetto sarà nicchia che scattando aria
hazra l'inglese è arrivato in ritardo al
matrimonio maledetto polipo no perché
quella è la moglie del polipo verrà
effettivamente che voi ci crediate o no
visto che cazzo qua c'è un polipo che si
mette la larga fantastico è una cosa che
vedete tutti i giorni non sei ancora
vestito devi essere presentabile lei ti
sta aspettando
ok ragazzi st mi devo perfetto sono io
che ho come abbai fantastico
prepariamoci per il matrimonio ragazzi
state per assistere un matrimonio alla
pa vj e all'oste tematico questo non so
che cos'è di preciso left click to greg
questo faccio un cuscino per prepararmi
correttamente al matrimonio infiliamoci
questo cuscino nel deretano credo sia la
murola ok allora guardate allo specchio
che cazzo sta facendo
ai nuovi cuscini [ __ ] tanta ma
chiave non l'avevo vista perfetto allora
cosa mi serve st chiave allora non è
difficile vai così perfetto allo ragazzi
che cazzo ci dovrebbe essere più dietro
[Applauso]
resta è stato lui nove ragazzi abbiamo
soltanto sfondato muro chi se ne fotte
come faccio a camminare che non mi
ricordo più ah ok ok tutto chi ha tutto
chiaro a tutto
mi sono incastrato in uno specchio non
siamo rance parte c'è una cravatta sulla
porta vedo come mi spiega perchè ci
hanno aggravato la sua porta come che
faccia premere ok se ho trovato la
ragazza fantastica
la cosa che comunque ragazzi non mi sono
ancora spiegate come è possibile che un
cazzo di polipo riesca a sposarsi con un
essere umano soprattutto un polipo così
intelligente perché mi sembra veramente
incredibile ma che bello tutti gli
invitati saranno stracontenti ragazzina
figata che abbiate pazienza hanno
ragazzi non hanno fatto l'amore data
benissimo a casa non pensavo complimenti
è questa la torta vero miglia che bella
assaggiarne un pochettino afasie ma non
ti preoccupare nessuno sospettava nulla
solo un assaggino siamo ragazzi già
facciamo andare alla cerimonia perché
non era così vicina mi parve perfetto
devo prendere qualcosa di qui la bibbia
ok niente bb avrei commesso trovato
questo fiocco che mi renderà di sicuro
più sexy è la cosa che madonna come
cammina in modo sensuale cosa devo fare
qui lo devo meta perfetto ragazzi di
temi che vi stata la panda vedere questo
bel polipone più tentato dobbiamo
arrivare al mio [ __ ] matrimonio
togliti ragazzi ce la faccia togli
finale di serie c sono dimenticato di
portare un regalo alla mia donna quindi
porterò questo splendido attaccapanni
e la cosa mi piace usate
erano intenzione scusate devo arrivare
alla mia sposa bellissima scusate bene
ragazzi si siano dopo secoli grottole lo
so che ti stanno guardando tutti da un
giorno speciale ma cerca di essere
normale tranquillo ai cose normali fai
cose normali fai cose normali palco non
stuprare tua moglie all'altare ragazzino
ma questo è chiama su tre non è ancora
non è ancora il momento anton ed calmo
detto e tetto sono ingombranti mattino
che ti piace sto braccio sexy allora
allora donna io ti cedo quest'anello in
cambio della tua parte o perfetto grande
grazie mille sono sempre stato bravo a
tenere questo tipo di discorsi e mi
piace il fatto che non c'è neanche un
prete perché effettivamente siamo
sposati da soli io faccio se rimane lo
faccio io il prete chi se ne fotte
vai si può potete baxi però non fate
cose oscene perché ci sono anche dei
bambini
l'ong office cos'è cos'è
oddio sto cascando che cazzo suo ok è
superman no e 8 che vola nel cielo
libero ragazzina è una cosa veramente
pazzesca vedere un 88 del derby a sketch
mamma grande così ragazzi preparatevi
perché sta per iniziare una delle serie
con più senso in assoluto che io abbia
mai fatto attenta e lo so che è che
presto e che la vita da sposato e molto
molto difficile ma chissene forte alzala
perché cazzo fa la sveglia la deve
finire di scassare le balle ai rock toto
le due sole due del pomeriggio cazzo un
po tardi mi sono ok perfetto il cassetto
non me lo devo porta dietro
neanche l'altro tanto mette a posto mia
moglie chi se ne fotte vai così ma
tranquillo non sei d'anticipo per andare
a scuola sono soltanto le due del
pomeriggio evitate di fare casino in
casa che poi lo dico la mamma è brutti
stronzi ragazzi la cosa non mi piace per
niente ma andiamo in cucina perché ho
fame vedo che capisce amore mio che sei
già in cucina vede di prepararmi un
panino di nutella e stai zitta allo
ragazzi mi insegno come si fa un caffè
fatto con i contro maroni allora prima
di tutto non lo si dovrebbe spargere per
terra così tanto ma voi fate finta di
nulla amore ne mette un pochettino
perché diciamo che stamattina sono un po
addormentato quindi mi serve un po ma
non gli porta primi ktu stea devo
portare il latte alla bambina
allora i bambini dovrebbero imparare a
farsi le cose da soli perché noi che
posso fare io le cose ma non riporta voi
pensate io glie lo possa mettere nella
tazza ma glielo porto direttamente così
ed è lo bevi perché devi crescere
ma che cazzo ma che cazzo ho appena
riversato 2 litri di latte su una
bambina mi sembra giusto ragazzi sto
gioco non ha un cazzo di senso ma non
importa scusami amore mio
se faccio un po di casa grazie grazie
sei gentilissimo allora fatemi mary un
po di caffè che sono addormentato cazzo
rovesciato metà per terra ma chi se ne
fotte vai così tanto pulisci tu esci in
giardino perfetto beh c'è anche giardino
ragazzi stasera figata mi chiamo re
abitarci o ragazzi ma basta io mollo
tutto il video giardina giocato sono un
fenomeno
guardate come si estirpano né arbace
come si deve vai così è la cosa che mix
che è successo allora tu devi stare al
tuo posto
maledetta come faccio a farla o che come
un mezzo e mi sono un'anima sapevo di
robin 2 vecchio vicini maledetti ragazzi
vicini sono sempre più franzina è
previsto guarda che l'erba del vicino è
sempre più verde bastardo ricordatelo
ragazzi stiamo finendo male [ __ ]
per quanti miei minimi da giardino tutti
dentro il cap ranzi te li do di metterlo
che già stiamo facendo
sì il tuo giardino è una merda sappilo a
mare che sta succedendo laggiù
niente niente stavamo scambiando quattro
chiacchiere giusto così ragazzo il micam
per otto dei sei un genio
fatelo dire sei un [ __ ] genio è una
casa ma andiamo andiamo all'acquario
[Musica]
cazzo dice non si capisce la minchia
quando parla occhio del ma non stato lo
capiscono tutti tranne noi praticamente
vabbè ci siamo ragazzi dobbiamo andare
alla quarta siamo all'acquario find the
frozen pizza ma siamo in un supermercato
in un acquario fatemi capire da 8 a dead
al supermercato e una cosa che non si
vede proprio tutti i giorni marroni
importa facevo la spesa come si deve
hai preso l'ultima scatola di cereali
bastarda orta dead fermo la signora ma
visto che bei di indici sono nella pro
scaffale
bravissimo grande continui a guardare
tranquillamente i deal di sullo scaffale
non faccia caso
a questo poi a viscusi lo volevo farle
le tette lo giuro è grande e che piano
tattico fa uno scaffale di mike ravel e
si tolga la mia donna mi sta pestando il
tentacolo non vede le faccio causa sat
conosco un buon avvocato dello stato a
sorprendere la una mela devo andare a
prendere una mela o mi scusi mi scusi
non è la mia intenzione salve senta devo
prendere lamela perfetta perché ci sono
steri luce di tutto sono finito nel
reparto ananas non fa vj le ordinarie
del suo se ho bisogno di sei bella
gnocca come va tutto a posto ha notato
che gli guardavi culo è nella ragazzi e
non risponde un cazzo di nessuno quindi
vado sul retro non ne frega la minchia
in al vento e cazzo dopo ore di ricerca
e su big bang che cazzo ci fai qui e
sembra gazich è il mio vicino cuoco che
sta tentando di ucciderli di nuovo
perché ragazzi aiuto aiuto
ok perfetto sono inciampato ma sono
ancora vivo sono ancora vivo mai così
mai così grande dio mio santo eccoti qui
mi sto preoccupando i nostri stava
soltanto di stuprarmi un cuoco ma tutto
tranquillo tranquilla donna ho preso
tutto hai già messo tutto qua ci siamo
che perché abbiamo fatto la spesa
perfetto ragazzi allora dobbiamo andare
ma cosa bella non si capisce un cazzo
la cosa che mi mi disturba di più di
questo videogame che lei che la ragazza
la donna lo guarda come se fosse una
persona normale la chiazza un polipo
sveglia non era a bel podio la faccia
triste dandy andare all'acquario senti
svegliati fa il vero padre ci siamo
ragazzi siano all'acquario che cazzo di
faccia spaventa facciata madonna ma che
avesse visto un mostro ma che è calmo 8
del stai tranquillo siamo un acquario ma
non cucinano in casa ecco come me ti
vedo così spaventato è un cazzo di
polipo sveglia e normale che tra paura
la seva all'acquario dio santo io non
c'ho speranze congregazione cosa ve la
voglio dire è il primo a non aveva senso
già di suo
questo ne ancora meno di prima perché la
cosa inguardabile ma non importa anche
ragazzi se vita è piaciuto come solito
lasciato un commento mi piace anche a
paesi a di facebook come ogni video slot
nella descrizione senatore chiti
scrivete quindi ci rivediamo il
proseguito ragazzi